bill Lambert a paramedic and firefighter
was visiting the zoo with his family he
happened to bring along his Sony video 8
handicap I was videotaping over here and
we heard a scream and then a thud
crowd started screaming and then those
new people ran by me what happened
without even realizing I was still
recording
I automatically ran and followed him
over here to see what was going on
but I just zoomed my camera in to see
what she was carrying and she was
carrying a small child she was Pennock
cradling the child in one arm and then
walking the other way and it looked she
kept looking back at the other gorillas
like she was trying to get away from the
other ones and just kind of felt like
she was trying to protect him
first thing that came into my mind I ran
up the ramp and then when I saw her
again she was sitting on the log there
pretty much cradling the boy and almost
looked like she was rocking
that was just amazing and then they hit
her with the water again and that's when
she put the boy down and took off bindi
placed the boy near an access door where
keepers could retrieve him
the toddler suffered only minor injuries
and made a full recovery
it's November of 2002 Richard and Kathy
Auckland are in the salute Game Reserve
in Tanzania celebrating their second
wedding anniversary as they head into
the bush
Richard trains their mini DV camera upon
lions hippos monkeys and eventually a
family of Masai giraffe then two male
giraffes catch their attention they just
had a different stance they just looked
more aggressive and we'd never seen that
before the driver he's thoughts and he
turn off the engine and when that
happens you know that was what start
looking about what's going on and he
thought they were gonna fight
and witches for oh my gawd
Richard and Kathy feared they're
witnessing of fight to the death
this was boxing without rules and
partway through the video I said to the
guy do they think I scare each other
because I was watching this and I was
thinking this could be fatal
the heated battle lasts just two and a
half minutes but to the auckland's it
feels much longer if it was two lines
fighting you'd say wow they're fighting
but you would expect that kind of
behavior but nothing drops in the end
the slightly smaller adolescent on the
left appears to have had enough
he simply picks up and walks away in
March of 2008 an intriguing video popped
up on YouTube that had a lot of people
scratching their heads
mark Fang and lizallen shot and posted
the video it was just an amazing
experience and Mark always has the
camera with him and he's always filming
mark trained the lens of his high-def
camcorder on a female elephant named Tom
in just under five minutes han completed
painting the elephant she then added a
flower as a finishing touch and she put
every last detail into it and when she
knew she was finished she stepped away
and was very pleased with herself